see the problem that I've come to
realize with scientific research as guys
like you use them is that it it relies
on a lot of the times there are surveys
right so a real good example was
um you know Alexander uh from date psych
um I had him on my Channel at one point
and we were talking about his research
on top deal breakers in dating
um and as we were going through uh
women's deal breakers and men's deal
breakers
I came to realize there's there's like
25 or 30 deal breakers that women would
list when you know he surveyed them but
do you know what was missing that was
obvious to me
oh it's the behavior I mean right okay
it's height because oh they didn't say
height none of the women in the survey
acknowledge that height was important
but women disqualify men routinely on
dating apps if they look short or uh if
they aren't tall enough for them so it's
interesting you know to
um you know get into the science and the
research and say you know well you know
this is this is science-based evidence
on uh you know good advice for dating
and stuff like that but when you ask
somebody for their opinion or to take a
survey or you know however it's
presented to like maybe you need a lie
detector attached at the same time when
you're asking them the question sort of
thing you know what I mean that's not
even yeah so I can like it can be flawed
yeah so for me survey data generally
isn't good enough to believe something
right so I'll I'll give you I'll give
you a very similar example of this so
you have to when I am assessing whether
something's true ideally and sometimes
the evidence just isn't there sometimes
it is it's like okay we've we've got
survey data and nothing else so it's
like it's between survey data and like
personal experience and okay maybe we
need to do more research here but when
it's good right we get survey data but
we combine it with behavioral data and
then also stuff that's kind of in
between so for example
with the height thing right you could
look at what height filters do women set
on dating apps right it's kind of in
between it's not quite behavioral I
guess you could say setting a filter is
a behavior but it is a self-report of
their preference but it's a self-report
in a higher Stakes context so it's more
persuasive a good example of this would
be if you ask people and this is true
for men and women right
if you ask people okay what do you want
in a mate
they're going to tell you oh I want
someone honest I want someone loyal I
want someone kind right and then they
probably do want those things right
those are those are the those are the
top three and you know top four types of
traits usually the top five are all
these like personal qualities that are
quite important
but if you look at behavioral data looks
come out over and over again right at
close to the top of the list if not the
top right exactly so so it's like yes
you say you want someone honest loyal
and kind but then when you actually go
to selectmates which the first thing
you're you're looking at you're looking
at looks and you're filtering based on
that now some would say okay that
doesn't mean that looks are the most
important thing it's just the easiest
thing to filter People based on but I
would say that
when you look at a special another
behavioral way of getting at this is to
look at partner correlations right so
for example men say that they don't care
that much about a woman's education
level right so you look at the you talk
about the self report so I just said a
self-report example that would be you
know very red pilled here's one that's
well it kind of goes the other way
sometimes right men say they don't
really care about a woman's education
level
but then you look in practice and almost
every college-educated man is only
dating women who are also college
educated right correct yeah so the The
Internship had a um actually had a gal
on my ladies night podcast the other
night and she's in the San Francisco Bay
area and she was telling us that she was
disqualified almost routinely sometimes
by guys that were higher income earners
because she didn't have a degree and
didn't earn enough money yes exactly so
so a lot of these red pill guys right
they'll say oh it's not just you know
survey data isn't real survey data isn't
real and it's like okay let's look at
some behavioral data yeah you guys are
right looks matter a lot more than women
say right the education status money in
practice men say men say they don't care
about these things when you ask them on
a survey but then in practice men are
dating roughly in their own income
especially in the west right and this
this really is Western data
um roughly in their own income range
right definitely in their own class
range if you were to stratify the Sexes
um based on you know nor normal
variation in how this x is earned and
then also definitely in their education
range we don't see these big mismatches
so yes I completely it also depends on
on who you're going to ask to and where
they're at in their stage of life like
if you're talking to an older more
seasoned gentleman that's that's got his
money sorted he probably doesn't really
care that much about her education and a
degree on the wall and more about Youth
and beauty and potentially if he wants a
family and children fertility right so
um these things all seem to be moving
targets of my estimation is that
something that you would agree with or
disagree with I think you'd be surprised
Matt I believe it's true for you right
and I think that as when we're putting
on
when we're trying to be critical
thinkers right we have to step outside
of our own preferences and our own
experience right because I would have
some bias biases based on what I there
are times when I you know open up a
study and I'm like well I you know I
really care about this thing and then I
realize oh it seems like actually
overall this isn't something that's
super important to other men and vice
versa I would say that most men who are
educated whether they say it or not in
their behavior they exhibit a preference
towards other educated
um towards other educated individuals
and part of this it might not it might
not come out as a direct effect you have
to keep in mind that it's like
if you're as you say like like a guy
who's got his money together educated
that sort of thing you're probably a
pretty smart guy right just just
probably a very few people get rich by
accident right there are some people who
get it through inheritance that kind of
thing but usually it's like okay
you've been solving complicated problems
at a high level for decades and that's
why you have money
that type of guy in practice you know in
in his speech he might say oh I don't
care about her education level I don't
care about how smart he is I just want
someone young and beautiful and then
it's like in practice you know you're on
the second date and you're bored because
you guys can't talk about anything
um so I I think a lot of these guys they
they say they don't care about it but
they do we don't see huge IQ mismatches
in dating typically we don't see huge um
salary gaps in dating typically um
although you know this is when you're
correcting for already the differences
in wage Gap
um the differences in wages between the
taxes I apologize and then also we don't
see these huge gaps in education
generally People Mate quite assortively
on that even though it's it's if it's
going to go up in One Direction yeah
it's generally the women dating up I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out